[Music]
is there a possibility that the
definition of hate speech metastasizes
and broadens in such a way to serve very
particular
silencing objectives right where there's
a certain suppressive effect
on desired groups by
categorizing as hate speech even
commentary op-eds etc
that ask questions related to topics
that are deemed sensitive or
offensive
fill in the blank to a particular group
so what are the stakes and then what do
you think things might look like three
to five years from now
the stakes are really huge
because
they go to the question of where we're
going to talk to each other
what we're going to say to each other
and how politics is going to interface
with the online universe and the online
universe is not going away you know it's
going to continue to be
in expanded ways
the central way that we communicate
about tons and tons
of subjects so the stakes couldn't be
higher and they're really high on both
sides
they're high for people broadly speaking
on the left who are worried
that january 6 style
extremism
could go from being peripheral in the
united states to mainstream
with dire consequences for democracy
and they're consequential to people on
the right who are worried as you were
sort of hinting
that
principles of
limiting speech to avoid what counts as
quote-unquote hate speech or political
correctness
could actually impede
public debate
and discourse in a way that's really
destructive because it means that
certain points of view can't be heard
and if they can't be heard then they're
delegitimated and potentially harmed
so the stakes are huge and they're huge
on both sides
can the definition of hate speech be
expanded in a way to suppress certain
political points of view
not only is the answer yes but that's
really why the concept of hate speech
was invented in the first place
you know in especially germany but
elsewhere in europe after world war ii
in the aftermath of the rise of nazism
lots of moderate centrist people thought
wait what went wrong in our society
you know i mean germany had a liberal
constitution in the 1920s
and it had all kinds of economic
problems and all kinds of struggle
between different political parties but
it had a nominally ordinary liberal
constitution
and in that environment communists were
able to express their views nazis were
able to express their views and
ultimately
that liberal democracy failed and was
replaced by the nazi state and so
centrist moderate said we really need to
rethink the idea that free speech lets
you express all kinds of views including
nazi views because people might believe
those views
and so the idea of prohibiting certain
kinds of speech certain kinds of hate
speech was based on the worry
that in europe it could happen here
because it had just happened there
that that kind of
talking had led to action and had led to
the collapse of constitutional
government
so the whole point of outlawing certain
kinds of hate speech was to prohibit
certain kinds of political views from
gaining the kind of foothold that would
lead them to take power it was different
in the us
in the u.s
the free speech movement in the 20s
tended to take the view in the 30s tend
to take the view that oliver wendell
holmes jr one of the most famous supreme
court justices took where he said
listen you can't shout fire in a crowded
theater so there are some limits
if you're about to overthrow the
government in the next few moments
yes we can shut you up but he said if
through calm reasonable conversation
the ultimate effect of speech is to
bring about
he said the dictatorship of the
proletariat you know a victory of
soviet-style communism he said i think
my job is to let that happen
that's his most extreme formulation in
favor of free speech but it's damn
extreme and he said it in a supreme
court opinion and so that was the kind
of absolutist view that said as long as
you're not about to
imminently cause violence
you can say whatever you want and if
that undermines our political norms
that's fine
so from that point of view from that
holmesian point of view
in the u.s we really
shouldn't want it to be the case
that prohibitions on hate speech end up
really limiting what you can say in
public
that's the kind of strong pro free
speech view
the worry is
are we in a place where germany was
in the 20s you know are is january 6 the
kind of historical event
that shows you that there's a genuine
risk that people could try to overthrow
the government of the united states and
you know as more details come out not
just about january 6 but about donald
trump's various efforts to try to
reverse the outcome of the election
there is a point of view that says
that's not so crazy
you know our democracy maybe is in
greater danger than it's been at in the
past and maybe for that reason speech
should be limited so i think what's
hardest about this problem is a lot of
what you think
depends on how you assess a real world
situation
do you actually believe
they were in danger of enough people
getting on board
with dangerous bad crazy ideas
and breaking our democracy
that you need to do things like d
platform donald trump
or do you think look we're fine you know
sure january 6 was terrible but that was
only a relatively small number of people
and donald trump didn't succeed in
overthrowing the outcome of the election
and we shouldn't mess with our basic
free speech norms which have served us
so well
until now
so that leaves the question of the the
base case
to me the the most probable
outcome
is that
we continue to have
a pretty robust
system of private actors including
newspapers and social media platforms
and others limiting speech
pretty extensively
but we also have some other social media
actors whether it turns out to be
twitter or some startup social media
entity that have totally different rules
that are much closer to ordinary free
speech rules that are much closer to the
idea that you can say whatever you want
and then we would get a more expanded
ecosystem
in which
if you really want to say something to a
lot of people you're going to find some
venue in which you can say it
and my guess is again more probable than
not
that if the market does that the courts
will then back away
from speculating about maybe whether
they should step in to intervene
and limit and allow a limitation of what
these social media companies
do and that's because i just don't think
it's sustainable in the long run
that half or even you know 35 percent of
the public is supporting someone for
president
and that person has no major social
media outlet i just don't think that's
practically
probable or realistic either the social
media outlets or some social medias will
shift to allow that kind of speech
or new social media outlets will come
into existence or someone will buy one
of the existing ones and flip it so in
those scenarios
there will be some mechanism for all
kinds of speech to get out there and
then the us will probably ultimately
preserve at least the core of our free
speech tradition probably but that's
just the base case you know you could
imagine it you can imagine it going the
other way in that you can imagine the
government intervening
and saying we're gonna have much more
aggressive requirements
passed by state legislatures or others
that say that the social media companies
can't silence
hate speech and then what would happen
is we would sort of go back to internet
1.0 where you really could say anything
you wanted somewhere on the internet and
you could be as nasty as you wanted and
you could be as dangerous as you wanted
no one could really do anything about it
so that that is also a possible scenario
that could
that could potentially emerge it may be
that the social media platforms with
their central dominance over so much of
our speech will turn out to have been an
artifact of a certain moment
in the history of the web you know web
2.0 moment and in a web 3.0 moment maybe
they just won't matter as much even if
they continue to use the kinds of
content moderation standards that they
presently have
you